but first as you might have guessed
DeSantis launches that's the focus of
tonight's angle
[Music]
let's see so
here we are yeah like so
um just to simplify that all right great
so let's see if we just keep crashing
huh I'm super excited to
um have uh Governor Santos uh make this
uh
okay we're being a little naughty here
yeah it was a little glitchy but you
have to laugh at yourself that kind of
stuff happens to us all the time on the
anger mangle but Rhonda scientist
announces presidential vid tonight of
course but when not plagued with
technical issues the question and answer
uh period especially was really
important like when he pledged he's
going to reign in our fat bloated
government
buckle up when I get in there because
the the status quo is not acceptable and
we are going to make sure that we
reconstitutionalize this government and
these agencies are totally out of
control there's no accountability and we
are going to bring that in a very big
way actually legislate so you're not
delegating to the bureaucracy key issues
regarding how to enforce federal law
yeah the bureaucracy is strangling the
American people and our freedom and he
addressed that specifically but long
before he announced tonight the jackals
on the left had decided that he in fact
could even be scarier than Trump
there are a lot of younger people in
that party that are much scarier
DeSantis for one this guy is a fascist
this is the coming straight out of the
authoritarian Playbook this is what's so
uh disturbing about DeSantis DeSantis is
almost
um accelerated the the racism as the
point in his quest to run the most
right-wing fascist primary campaign ever
DeSantis is throwing all the right wing
pudding at the wall with
and now something from Vanity Fair
yesterday that was so bizarrely vicious
it's almost a parody of itself kind of
like that Montage we just played for you
a piece that was titled DeSantis will
formally announce his 2024 bid with Elon
Musk because apparently David Duke
wasn't available and neither were other
Neo-Nazi sympathizers
at very subtle kids
now of course this isn't anything that
President Trump and candidate Trump
hadn't already been subjected to except
a thousand times worse because they
tried and are still trying to kill him
politically with federal and state
investigations lawsuits and oh no big
deal just two impeachments
Donald Trump is deliberately putting out
a racist bigoted nativist appeal as well
as a neo-fascist appeal the emotionally
unstable Donald Trump he's a white
nationalist he's a fascist he's embraced
violence Trump they're not only lying
but being casually racist bending over
backwards uh uh being an apologist for
Vladimir Putin and for Russia
do you notice the similarity here they
have the same pattern no matter who the
Republican is now most people would have
melted into a puddle of goo in the first
month of these types of attacks but
remember Trump just keeps going
there was no collusion with Russia there
was no obstruction and none whatsoever
and it was a complete and total
exoneration
it's a shame that our country had to go
through this we are a nation that no
longer has a free
and fair press fake news is all you get
and they are the enemy of the people
we are a nation where free speech
is no longer allowed we're going to
bring energy down way down we're going
to get the interest rates down we're
going to get back to a great life
and now he wants to take the fight back
to the White House to finish the job
that he started now think about that for
a moment president Trump was determined
to run again despite knowing that he had
if he had quietly left politics after
the election
the attacks and the legal threats most
certainly would have stopped
so the DeSantis Trump's only viable
competitor have that same Moxie that
same it's almost a lust for battle
and can he get stuff done in Washington
when they're going to be throwing acid
at him 24 7.
and while running a national campaign
and the national media Spotlight that is
hot is a hell of a lot different than
running a state
the signs are that DeSantis like Trump
does have the spine to fight through it
all and not lose focus on actually what
matters consider what he's gotten done
against the media and the Democrat
freakouts in his own state
this is political political excuse me of
all places that talked about his
accomplishments just last legislative
session one of the most productive
stretches of right-wing law making any
state seen in years week after week
legislators push through measures
dealing with abortion guns the death
penalty immigration schools and gender
identity sometimes admit protests inside
the capitol
and after winning reelection by nearly
20 points let's face it DeSantis knew
that he had the Leverage The Mojo to
actually get his agenda passed into law
desantis's allies in the legislature
delivered nearly everything he asked for
whether it was imposing new regs on
Disney or a law designed to block China
from buying land in Florida
now you know he's getting under their
skin when even the White House got into
the lie that because DeSantis banned the
Twisted sexual propaganda being shoveled
out to Florida school kids he's also
Banning books and poems
and
Florida Elementary School do you have a
comment on that move the president his
administration certainly stand with her
Banning books is censorship period
that's what that is when you ban a book
you are censoring it is uh it limits
American Freedom Americans freedom
no they're just for rewriting books now
of course their claim is patently false
the book was simply moved from
elementary school to a middle school
where it was deemed more appropriate
but get used to it gov this is what
they're going to do now even more absurd
though is that the same people who
praise Biden's Mastery of stage and
substance are jumping all over
desantis's demeanor
look I he's hard to get along with one
on one he's pretty awkward person what
you're saying he's hard to get on one
with one-on-one and he's not a great
campaigner the guy who by the way is not
expanding his own base of support and is
also not doing anything to help with the
awkwardness because he's awkward too
awkward
I'll show you awkward
there's a lot of other for example the
idea that we're uh in terms of uh taxes
that they refuse to for example we uh
I was able to balance the budget and
pass everything from the global warming
Bill anyway
for example as the press and the pundits
and the former president are going to
use a flamethrower against DeSantis it's
going to be tempting for him to fall
back on the cultural issues that have
dominated his profile really for the
past year or so
and as important as those are and we
certainly spent a lot of time on the
angle talking about them he and all
Republicans should remember what the
voters really care about they're telling
us the latest Harvard Harris survey
tells us that not drag shows or Disney
no it's the economy inflation and high
prices immigration that are bothering
people so both DeSantis and Trump should
remember that Reagan won in 1980
hammering Carter's economy and Clinton
won in 92 hammering Bush's economy
as tempting and fun as the other issues
are to bat around the path to Victory is
offering credible solutions to what
worries voters most but you know we
spent a whole life savings to get a good
retirement account and now we see it
dwindling like dwindling dwindling
dwindling everything's just getting more
expensive and it makes it harder and
harder for people even working seven
days a week to actually you know make a
living inflation uh has taken up you
know a bite out of out of everything
it's getting more and more difficult you
know to uh to manage all that
now no wonder buying this numbers not
handling the economy are among the worst
I've ever seen with just 33 percent
approval and only 24 percent of
Americans say National Economic
conditions are in good shape
so I was a little surprised that
Governor DeSantis and his hosts spent
almost no time on the issue tonight
that's going to need to change on the
stump
so how about saying something like my
energy policy will help push gasoline
back down closer to around 230 a gallon
and my trade policy is going to help
Main Street not Wall Street my border
policy is going to tackle the fentanyl
nightmare that's killing our people
in my industrial policy is going to
insulate us from China's Global
Ambitions and aggression
I'd vote for that
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else